allegations of domestic abuse alcoholism
drugs a severed finger those are just a
few of the things we've heard during
testimony in the johnny depp amber heard
trial welcome to entertainment tonight
nichelle turner has the night off now
today with johnny depp's turn to take
the stand and trust me when i tell you
it was explosive
never did i myself
reach the point of um
striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
in my life
it's very strange when one day your
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds you're
quasimodo
the depth drama really kicked in 30
minutes into his testimony the actor
stood up and dramatically recreated how
his own mother stumbled after overdosing
on pills during a suicide attempt when
he was a child i knew that something was
dreadfully wrong and she was quite cruel
there was physical abuse which could be
in the form of
an ashtray being flung at you
johnny is suing amber for 50 million
dollars claiming defamation as a result
of this op-ed amber wrote which he says
depicts him as an abuser the actor
claimed today he saw an unusual red flag
early on in their relationship amber
would get visibly upset if she didn't
get to take off johnny's boots at the
end of the day you just said
what did you just do
what did you do
what do you mean
you took your boots
off i said yeah yes i did you you you
were busy you know no no no that's my
job that's what i do and then
within a year or a year and a half she
had become another person almost
he's an actor we know actors rehearse
their lines and in court it's the same
way
as for the courtroom look entertainment
attorney mitra aharian who has been
following the case says johnny's cleaned
it up it's playing out just like a movie
would the initial few days was really
presenting the johnny depp that we all
know and love you know with kind of the
more rugged look the jack sparrow look
the longer hair and then as the days
progress they have him with his hair
back really presenting himself as if
he's in court a lot more polished
this afternoon depp addressed his drug
use i have taken these substances over
the years on and off to numb myself it
was essentially it was just
self-medication
[Music]